[Music]
so did you guys know that 200 years
before they did the famous witch trials
the salem witch yes
there was werewolf trials in europe what
yeah i'm not kidding
that's sick as [ __ ] that guy's too hairy
no dude they were convicting men and
some women of
transforming into werewolves
and mutilating they might be dominican
there are certain ethnic groups that our
nationalities that are just more prone
to hearing history
armenian dominican you've brought you
the murderer is really hairy really
[ __ ] hairy
it's a joke about like women having
mustaches like chest hair right yeah i
don't know about that part
mustaches it's a thing
yeah and the arms they're convicted of
eating kids and mutilating them oh no
okay that is a lot more than just hairy
skin while being accused of being
werewolves
i mean wait did they find did it come
because like kids
were being missing and eaten and then
they're like what the heck yeah they
would they would find mutilated kids so
they didn't think maybe a [ __ ]
pedophile no no no no no no or a walleye
they're like it's probably a werewolf
yeah yeah or is it
like how did they just have somebody
that they were suspected of werewolf and
just wait for a full moon [ __ ] idiot
what's the difference between a werewolf
and a lichen what the [ __ ] is that what
is the liken
lichens are are um
they're the albino werewolves got it
okay sorry when i was when i was you
guys hear that from uh
kate beck and sells uh uh underworld
underworld [ __ ]
it's the vampires versus the likes they
didn't say werewolves though so i was
like what's it like a werewolf then i
don't know
that's why i was asking i [ __ ] that
dude this movie kate beck and said i'm
gonna find what a [ __ ] liking is
l-y-c-a-n that's all i know
yeah i like no like lichen's got to be
its own thing yeah is that different
from werewolves too oh they are what the
[ __ ] what are they just calling
werewolves oh no wonder my friend's name
is like liking something he owns wolves
they're a second breed werewolves i was
actually kind of right oh second breed
wait can i have some presents so what's
the first [ __ ] anthony dude yeah you
did pretty good i'll give it to you man
what's the second breed they're a second
breed of werewolves i think the first
breed is werewolf yeah that's six so
what's the second breed
lichens so you mean like so like it's
like if i get bit and i'm i'm turned
into a werewolf then you're liking
you're liking me
oh i'm a lycan i'm not a werewolf
because you're the second breed now
i do think i do think we're making this
up hold on no this is all historical
fact i'm on underworld.fandom.com i
thought i was a werewolf and what about
team jacob what's that one team jacob is
is um that fool's a creep bro yeah
that's he's a werewolf in real life no
in the movie oh i'm like oh hey that's
what that floor didn't he [ __ ] up in
real life and then why you like stop
working at it really look it up taylor
lautner
i thought i thought everybody loved him
no no that's the other guy edward he was
a weirdo
the new batman batman dude everyone
[ __ ] swoons over that
jacob but now that he's playing batman
get the [ __ ] out of here no you know
he's batman i don't know i don't want
him to be batman
he's a good batman oh you just look you
know what he doesn't look tough he
doesn't he looks like a [ __ ] in the
suit yeah i'll be honest scrawny right
batman looks like he's a 14 year old kid
in a halloween like bart you know that's
what i was gonna say he's gonna go work
out with bart man come on get him right
for the movie please why don't you hit
him up maybe he's the modern man no
he's going to come in and be like i'm
going to cancel you i'm going to cancel
it i'm going to write a [ __ ] tit i'ma
write some [ __ ] on twitter i'll open
letter about you oh that's his power
dude he even says on the trail he's like
i'm vengeance what do you think that is
that's like karen [ __ ] yeah
there's an open letter to gotham city
stop the crime guys two joker
i don't really like the way you're like
handling all this stuff right now i love
the mini keyboard i might [ __ ] like
this guy why are you guys doing crimes
tonight
i need to go to sleep okay
wait so um so you guys are going to see
it what year were they doing these uh
werewolf trials in europe in 16th and
17th centuries and did they say which
countries all throughout europe holy
[ __ ] yeah did they say how many people
ended up like uh dying in these trials
but it's tough because historical
records are whack and so like the
historical records would say like you
know they were werewolves
you know what i mean were they as dumb
as the witch ones for sure because the
which ones are like this they're like
we're gonna drown you
and if you're a witch you're gonna come
back to life you're going to of course
nobody's going to do that situation
but also they were tortured and then
many of them admitted to being
werewolves well because they're being
tortured so they killed them anyway they
admitted it and they're like i knew it
let's kill them yeah by the way the
internet today is basically the same
[ __ ] like they admitted it
that's the best [ __ ] they're gonna
[ __ ] love it we just got instagram
werewolf trials nowadays that's true
i mean humans
haven't changed much right it's just now
on online form people still have the mob
and like
there are real witches today though you
know they're like uh
actual witch uh club sectors um edu uh
not educational like training there's
like you you train you get into like
different like which circles and then i
forget what uh what the word is when
you're in training you're uh wiccan
i think that's what witchcraft is
wiccans or something
there is something for when you are
talking about um are they effective
they're trying to like bring back
these like celtic things or like like
how like europe lost its traditions to
christianity yeah i
like not like not like the witches that
we know where they write a brooms trick
thinking they're like well those like i
know a little bit closer to that but
more in like the tarot card reading
realm oh like the cyber oh
they are considered witches like the
like the traveling gypsies and stuff
that have a crystal ball and [ __ ] but
they like literally consider themselves
witches and there's like a ritual it's
for people to like learn be educated in
it and then be uh ordained as like a
fellow witch i want the halloween
witches
i like that new harry potter [ __ ] where
people are like [ __ ] taking way too
seriously
it's pretty hilarious i love harry
potter so whatever i like not into harry
potter i like that old school [ __ ] like
how they have the like the druids and
like all those like those guys that that
are trying to be europe before the
catholics came that shit's crazy druids
dude always god they are like painting
themselves all these they look like
hella tribal and stuff yeah
it's pretty dope before merlin are you
more vampires or werewolves what do you
guys think i think i like werewolves i
feel like werewolves more
if i could choose to be one where's it
no no i wouldn't i don't know
why is werewolves whack what about teen
wolf i'm more cuz i'm thinking blade
kind of vampire yeah i like michael j
fox yeah no but he's a he's a day walker
day walker yeah vampire world is way
better and he's black so he's got swag
he's definitely true you can't just like
say vampires in general are just like
more silent they're sexual they're all
pale though you know sex appeal yeah
tell me what's
[ __ ] werewolves like hump [ __ ] that's
true werewolves are cucks dude yeah
it's all about vampires
they have no control of themselves
yeah that's true i think werewolves need
a like a overhaul like branding yeah
they need a better movie to kind of just
put them out there yeah but like do
werewolves um again just
please correct me if i'm wrong do
werewolves have to because they turned
into werewolves on the full moon of the
month right um it depends because
sometimes they turn werewolves on the
moonlight
sometimes they play basketball and slam
kind of yeah that's true
but then when you think about a vampire
you think like a smooth like seductive
dude and when you think of a werewolf
you're like rapists get out of here yeah
i kind of get you always give that vibe
in movies don't they yeah we can kind of
rape you yeah the werewolves are usually
like the [ __ ] peasants or like an
ironworker and [ __ ] and they're like
[ __ ] dirty i'm thinking about it
vampires are like potter
i'm thinking about professional lupine
from harry potter what do you think the
kid
in teen wolf what do you think the kids
on the other team thought was going on
like you got a [ __ ] werewolf on her
team yo
michael j fox suck it from half at
halftime he like grows all his [ __ ]
hair then you don't think that to each
other like hey what the [ __ ] going on
i think he was traveling bro he barely
dribbled the whole time yeah he was
traveling absolutely
but you see in all those in all those
werewolf scenarios it's like you
live a normal life and then you have
that secondary life but i feel like for
vampires it's like you only live the
vampire life because you can't be out
during the day you're you're only
it's so dope yeah that's like the john
wick underworld like once you're an
assassin you're just an assassin that's
it that's what i think about werewolves
it's like okay silver bullet that's all
they got everything else is like
whatever there's not much like density
to it yeah you know what i'm saying rose
are whack bro really and i also like
that part in blade where like you know
he's still a vampire so he still [ __ ]
fiends for human blood so he has to give
him those injections he's like can you
see his face
you felt it i was like oh [ __ ] i was
gonna get to these chills right now dude
but also too there's way more vampire
movies than there are werewolf movies i
don't like how werewolves you don't know
yourself like you become something else
and you just like have amnesia like it's
kind of like fight club you know spoiler
alert and you ruin your clothes you're
like
you can't
my mom gave me this yeah you wake up
[ __ ] express yeah
at least when you're a vampire you know
you're being a piece of [ __ ] because
you're doing it all yeah but then you
gotta like prey on humans specifically
right like that's easy that's easy i
mean unless it's like interview like a
interview with the vampire where he like
you know got the the rats and the dogs
and [ __ ] that's then i wouldn't want to
be a vampire that's the way dexter you
pick on shitty people oh that's true are
the people that wronged you
you're a little [ __ ] and i want to
[ __ ] suck your blood
co-workers
vampires are like
coke addicts and then
werewolves
they're more like meth heads yeah yeah
that's true like it's the dif that's the
difference you sure like really really
bad method yeah cuz werewolves are up
all night too
that's when the crazy
comes out
one of the things i wanted to say real
quick to end this um
because you guys are often about doing
equal punishment
it's been the theme of the day i would
say yeah um
they one of the things that they did to
the alleged werewolves is they would
strap them to like a a big cart wheel i
don't know and then they spin his ass
remove his skin with hot pinchers
and chop off his head before burning his
body the stick they really definitely
thought he's a werewolf
wow why
they had no other proof besides the guy
just admitting to it
i mean they're
this is this is they're just playing a
game of mafia they did have drawings of
him as a werewolf though
[Laughter]
it was pretty easy to convince people to
[ __ ] back then look at this drawing
right here that's him as a world over my
heart when i saw it how did people like
that back then actually build castles
and [ __ ] that's like dummies dude i
wonder where the [ __ ] origin of the
like the idea of the werewolf came to be
or or it existed they just made it up
dude but what are the places you made it
up i just saw one hairy ass european guy
dude where did batman come from
the armenian guy bit a kid
[Music]
you